recurring nightmares manipulative
mummies and a dad who's a real Beau is
afraid isn't necessarily meant to make
sense but let's try to entangle what
happened Major Spoilers ahead
with all this real things that happening
bow is afraid it's easy to go down a
rabbit hole of wondering what's real and
what isn't if you get too hung up on the
details you'll just end up with a
headache as far as Bo is concerned
everything in the movie happens for real
once Bo's perspective is the only one
that matters because the movie is
supposed to immersive you are completely
in Boze mind I want to put you in the
experience of being a loser
director ariaster told The Daily Beast
Bo's world is meant to be a clown mirror
of the real world that is awful in all
the same ways that our world is awful
but the dial is turned up Beau lives in
constant fear that the worst is going to
happen so in Bose world the worst
actually does happen every time without
fail of course it's not an accurate
representation of reality but it's
something more profound a glimpse into
the headspace of somebody with
overwhelming anxiety and serious mommy
issues
as one would expect in a movie titled
bow is afraid of bohus countless fears
ranging from irrational phobias to
legitimate reasons to be terrified but
one fear looms larger than all of them
what's both fears most is disappointing
his mother Mona Wasserman although she
doesn't appear in person until the
ending Mona casts a shadow over the
entire film her supposed death is what
kicks a story in motion and does bow
Journeys to attend a funeral he is
constantly worrying about what his
mother would want him to do later Beau
discovers that Mona isn't dead instead
she fakes her death to see how her son
would react moner is convinced that Bo
didn't try hard enough to reach the
funeral which only confirms a belief
that Beau never loved her what do you
think I should do I'm sure you'll do the
right thing sweetheart Mona tries to
control every aspect of Bo's life even
his thoughts at the end of the movie
Mona lists everything she feels Bo has
done wrong with his life even though
none of these were Bose false this of
course is Bo's worst fear come true
as Beau watches a play and fold on stage
he imagines himself as the star of the
play through the play bow envisions a
fairy tale version of his life the kind
of life he wishes he had Beau builds his
own home falls in love and has three
children even though this imagined Bow's
life is challenging it is still more
fulfilling than Bo's real life at least
a bow and the players are life filled
with purpose this is a good home I know
at the end of the play Beau is reunited
with his children at this moment the
real bow realizes that his fantasy can
never become reality whenever one of
Bo's Sons asked him what happened to
their mother Bo cannot answer he knows
it's impossible for him to ever start a
family for Bo this is a cruel reminder
that even in his imagination happiness
will forever be out of reach the play
demonstrates that Bo has missed the
opportunity to live a fulfilling life
because he is living in constant fear of
what might happen if he falls in love
alternatively if Bo is indeed cursed and
this moment proves that Beau never had a
chance he was always doomed to live a
lonely life
Roger and Grace take bow under their
wing after they accidentally hit him
with their car although they have an
empty bedroom they make their daughter
Tony share her room with Beau because
the empty bedroom once belonged to their
son Nathan before he died in combat Raja
and Grace worship Nathan they would
rather ask Tony to sleep on the couch
and disturb their Shrine to Nathan the
whole situation is absurd but there's a
grain of truth to it although Roger and
Grace's reactions are exaggerated they
still reflect the way that some people
prioritize honoring the dead over taking
care of the living this plot thread
mirrors Bo's relationship with his
mother Beaumont the loss of his mother
as much as any person would but Dr Cohen
accuses Beau of delaying the funeral and
disregarding his mother's final wishes
no matter that Beau would have gladly
come to the funeral if he hadn't been
recovering from an accident this is yet
another way that Bo is emotionally
manipulated by those around him
the theme of gills hangs over the entire
movie time and time again Beau blames
himself for things that are not his
fault or Beyond his control he feels
guilty because he has to lead the
funeral and because Tony's parents love
him more than they love her own daughter
during the play he has imprisoned for a
crime he didn't commit and he briefly
warned us if it actually was his fault
naturally Beau is being conditioned to
think this way by his mother in Bose
recurring nightmare Mona responds to her
son's questions about his father by
asking are you trying to hurt me if this
has any indicator of both childhood then
his mother was constantly accusing him
of hurting her Beau must have been
blamed so many times as a child that he
internalized it and now he blames
himself for everything without even
needing to be told by anyone
at the beginning of bow is afraid Beau
tries to tell his therapists about a
recurring dream later in the movie
viewers get to see Bo's dream which Mona
tells him is actually a memory in it
there are two versions of Beau one is Bo
as a young boy refusing to get in the
bath until his mother tells him what
happened to his father another bow is
behind the camera submissively waiting
in the bathtub and watching silently
when Mona banishes the other bow to the
attic this symbolizes her crushing bow
Spirit she is stomping out bow spark of
Independence and locking that side of
his personality away so that Beau will
remain completely dependent on her
judging by the movie's conclusion Mona
has probably succeeded
up leave me a message if you ever want
to speak to me again
it's hard to tell exactly what happened
to beau's father because the movie
offers three conflicting explanations at
first Mona tells Bo that his father died
the instant bow was conceived because
his father had the same genetic
condition that bohus later in the film a
man approaches Bo after the play and
says that his father is alive Bo even
begins to wonder if this man is actually
his father strangest of all is what Beau
discovers in the Attic from his
nightmare a giant penis with a face
which Mona tells him is his real father
for good reason viewers will be
thoroughly confused some viewers have
suggested that Bo's father was portrayed
this way because his identity is
irrelevant he just impregnated Mona and
walked out of her life others have
argued that it all represents Bo's
sexuality which he has locked away just
like his alternate self was locked away
Beau was brought up to believe that he
has a genetic condition that will kill
him instantly if he has sex beau's fear
of this comes to a figurative and
literal climax after he reconnects with
his childhood Crush Elaine and gets into
bed with her but to his utter surprise
Bo survives this moment embodies a
larger Epiphany for Beau as he discovers
what it's like to make decisions for
himself free from his mother's influence
it's exhilarating but at last it's too
good to last Elaine has died instead
seemingly from the same condition that
killed Bo's father does someone actually
have to die if Bo has sex most likely
Bose encounter was harmless but beau's
mother has scarred him so deeply that he
believes something horrible will happen
if he disobeys her both fears it might
be true so naturally that makes it true
for him
watching Bose afraid audience says may
be reminded of The Truman Show both
movies ultimately reveal that the
protagonist's loved ones are all
involved in a conspiracy and it turns
out that a parental figure with god-like
abilities is the one pulling all the
strings in The Truman Show it's Kristoff
in Beau It's Mona at the end of Beau is
afraid Boney reveals that Bo's therapist
works for her all along secretly
recalling all his therapy sessions with
Beau in retrospect that explains why the
therapist was so preoccupied with
telling Beau that it was okay to say bad
things about his mother to trick him do
you ever wish that she was dead what but
Grace and Roger in on it too after all
the couple has surveillance cameras
constantly pointed at Bow and Roger's
excuse for why he can't drive Bo to his
mother's house seems awfully convenient
of course since Grace is the one who
tells Beau where to find the camera
footage it's possible she could have
gotten cold feet the biggest question
mark is Elaine it's unclear if Elaine's
sudden death was all passive Mona's plan
or something Mona simply capitalized
done after it happened
after Beau discovers that Grace and
Roger was spying on him Tony tells him
you've failed your stupid test Tony
never elaborates on this but it's
possible she means that Mona's funeral
was a test of both dedication to his
mother and both failed because he didn't
beg hard enough for Tony's parents to
take him in in fact everything that
happens in the film could be seen as a
test of Bo's loyalty apparently Mona's
been watching Beau the whole time
waiting for him to screw up if it is a
test then Beau was set up to fail
nowhere is this more apparent than when
Dr Cohen a Mona humiliate bone a
dramatic trial that is clearly stacked
against him all this points to the
possible theory that Bo's entire
universe was created by Mona to test her
son after all Mona wasserman's hometown
of wasserton is clearly named after her
which suggests that the entire world
revolves around her the photos on Mona's
walls which showbo posing in
advertisements for his mother's business
into the possibility that Bo's memories
of his childhood could be no more real
than these advertisements and her
company logo appears everywhere in Bo's
life or perhaps Bo's world is a metaphor
for his mother's suffocating presence
Bo's Trail Ends when his boat explodes
presumably killing him although beau's
death seems random and pointless there
might actually be a method to this
madness one possible interpretation is
that the explosion demonstrates Mona's
total control over Bo's life she brought
him into this world and you can take him
right back out so she does exactly that
though she seems to immediately regret
it because viewers can hear her distance
sobbing or maybe Beau did successfully
kill his mother and the trial exists
only in his head as a manifestation of
his guilt perhaps the explosion is Beau
punishing himself for Mona's murder
alternatively there's another way to
read the ending of bow is afraid perhaps
Beau allows himself to die because he
knows that's the only way he can break
free of his mother's control while Mona
clearly enjoys tormenting Beau she
doesn't seem to want him dead as
suggested by her crying in the end once
again viewers may be reminded of a scene
from The Truman Show where Truman ties
himself to a boat in the middle of a
storm and then dares Kristoff to kill
him although beau's life is in his
mother's hands perhaps he will get the
final laugh because now he has figured
out exactly how to hurt her